vamos a ver otro repaso general de la
fotosíntesis y esta vez voy a dividirla
en dos grandes etapas probablemente ya
estás familiarizado con la palabra
fotosíntesis que se puede dividir en dos
partes foto y síntesis fotos se refiere
a que se va a utilizar la luz de alguna
manera y que se va a hacer con esa
energía luminosa o energía lumínica
bueno se va a sintetizar algo y en
particular lo que se va a sintetizar
como veremos es azúcar por lo tanto
vamos a pasar de la energía luminosa
permítanme escribir eso energía
luminosa
y vamos a utilizar esa energía luminosa
para sintetizar azúcar a muy grandes
rasgos obviamente esto es una visión muy
general y la energía luminosa no es lo
único que se necesita también vamos a
necesitar un poco de agua y a medida que
avancemos con este tema en vídeos
futuros veremos para qué es utilizada el
agua en realidad es una fuente de
electrones para hacer uso de esa energía
luminosa y también vamos a necesitar
algo de dióxido de carbono como fuente
de átomos de carbono porque hay una gran
cantidad de carbono en los azúcares
esencialmente se va a fijar el carbono
lo tomamos el dióxido de carbono gaseoso
y lo vamos a incorporar en las moléculas
orgánicas y finalmente en el azúcar y el
azúcar no es lo único que se sintetiza
otro subproducto de este proceso es el
oxígeno molecular
una vez que se toma un par de electrones
del agua y se toman los iones de
hidrógeno también todo lo que queda es
oxígeno y lo hace dos veces por lo que
se tienen dos oxígenos formando así
oxígeno molecular y este es un
subproducto de la fotosíntesis pero como
te podéis imaginar es muy importante
para la vida en la tierra tal como la
conocemos particularmente para nosotros
tendríamos dificultad para respirar si
esto no fuera un subproducto de la
fotosíntesis y lo que voy a hacer ahora
es dividir esto en dos grandes etapas y
estas dos etapas las podemos llamar
reacciones dependientes de la luz
reacciones
dependientes
d
la
luz
y la segunda etapa la voy a llamar el
ciclo de calvin ciclo d
calvin y como su nombre lo indica
las reacciones dependientes de la luz
dependen de la luz así que lo que está
sucediendo aquí es que vamos a tomar
energía luminosa y vamos a tomar el agua
como fuente de electrones y vamos a
utilizar estas dos cosas para producir
atp a partir de adp
por lo que vamos a producir atp que es
una reserva de energía y también vamos a
reducir el ndp
más en general ep h
que tiene energía como un agente
reductor fuerte así que esto es lo que
está sucediendo en términos generales en
las reacciones dependientes de la luz y
luego en el ciclo de calvin lo que vamos
a hacer es que vamos a tomar estos
productos de las reacciones dependientes
de la luz así que vamos a tomar nuestro
atp
y nuestro ndp h
y podemos utilizar su energía en
conjunto con un poco de dióxido de
carbono con el fin de producir azúcar
azúcar
y vamos a ver ya está todo aquí
me falta uno de los subproductos de las
reacciones dependientes de la luz uno
muy importante me falta el oxígeno
molecular así que una vez más esto es lo
que constituye la fotosíntesis pero se
puede dividir en estos dos segmentos en
las reacciones dependientes de la luz
está haciendo uso de la energía de los
fotones en la luz junto con los
electrones del agua para producir atp y
enea de ph que son moléculas que
almacenan energía y tenemos oxígeno
molecular como subproducto para poder
producir un oxígeno molecular
vamos a necesitar dos de estas moléculas
de agua y luego a medida que avanzamos
en el ciclo de calvin podemos tomar
estas moléculas el atp y el nea de ph
junto con algo de dióxido de carbono y
podemos usar eso para almacenar la
energía en forma de azúcar
y en los próximos vídeos vamos a entrar
en más detalle y veremos lo que ocurre
exactamente en estas reacciones
dependientes de la luz y lo que sucede
exactamente en el ciclo de calvin